for almost a century readers have turned
to the new yorker for its award-winning
journalism but for a lot of folks
they're not there for the words they
come for the cartoons they clip them
they screen grab them they put them on
display on the fridge on the wall next
to the phone wherever they are needed
most which is why we wanted to meet up
with emma allen the youngest cartoon
editor in the magazine's long history
she's published cartoons from the
serious and the high-minded to the dumb
and just plain funny but what's the
secret of a great new yorker cartoon in
the year 2022 here's the journey
ready to go yeah in a corner conference
room at the world trade center we
recently witnessed one of the most
high-stakes weekly conversations in
journalism let's just review there's a
sausage sausage riding a horse between
some of the very best minds in the
business who's talking the lobster
a debate over a simple question
is this funny
editor david remnick has final say over
what officially becomes a new yorker
cartoon i like this i love this but it's
emma allen who gets to decide what to
put before him it's a strange art form
that exists almost only at the new
yorker at this point allen's been in the
role since 2017 when she replaced
long-time cartoon editor bob mankoff did
he give you any advice about the new job
i mean i think he said you know you can
do it you pick what's funny and you get
rid of what's not funny and
fundamentally that is all there is to it
she was already doing that with words
editing humor articles on the magazine's
website when remnick suggested she tried
pictures too
you were 29 yeah
no one had ever been younger in the job
no one has ever been younger than i was
at 29. you were the youngest
but she's also more experienced than you
might expect a humor columnist in
college and before that a little kid who
collected new yorker cartoons
why would a kid be cutting out new
yorker cartoons i guess
for all the ones i understood i thought
they were hilarious and for all the ones
i didn't understand i sort of wanted to
unpack them or grow up enough to be able
to understand them
the new yorker there is a certain
reputation i'd be more apathetic if i
weren't so lethargic and if you don't
know otherwise you might think a new
yorker cartoon is a little fancy for you
oh
i get it that's kind of funny but don't
be so sure alan says yeah these are all
yeses while she won't reveal her
favorites she did agree to talk us
through a couple winners like this one
of a man and woman at dinner captioned
let me interrupt your expertise with my
confidence i mean her expression the
fact that she has so little wine in her
glass has clearly
been drinking steadily
exactly
yeah that detail alone is just like yep
and this classic there's just layers of
greatness to this on the internet nobody
knows you're a dog it opens up this
variety of other questions like what is
this dog doing on the internet it's sort
of like the joke sets off the potential
for all these other funny thoughts
that moment of yes
for you the editor
is it a laugh i will say i probably
laugh out loud
four times the entire process of looking
at a thousand cartoons
that's not a good ratio i have to say
yeah the thing that really will sell a
cartoon is an element of surprise
because i am i'm in this dead eye
infinite scroll mode if something
shocks me out of my stupor then
that is it's in or at least it's gotten
to the next stage where david reminick
has to also be surprised by it
from there some 60 finalists are
whittled down to about 20. oh the grand
opening
which the magazine purchases for future
issues okay that's going in all right
all right do you think a discerning
reader could notice a change in the last
five years that you've been at the helm
um
someone asked me a much less daft and
tactful version of that question right
when i started which is oh now that
there's a woman in charge or all the
cartoons going to be different and i was
like yes they're all going to be about
menstruation of course
but i mean i think i was hired because
of the imprint i could put on the
magazine and the the new voices i would
find and promote not not
despite it and about that mankoff
acknowledged in a washington post
article last year that many of the
cartoonists he worked with were a
diverse group when it came to height and
weight but that's about it as he said it
was a limited group of cartoonists and
there wasn't a lot of diversity so you
recruited people i started recruiting
people and immediately people were
sending me names of other people that
they were excited about ellie black and
serene lee are two of the cartoonists
she's brought in do you think there's
any difference in her tenure i think
there's definitely
more
different voices or different points of
view i do know
like how fortunate
it feels to
be able to like share your work with
somebody who takes it seriously and
listens to you both do say they feel
supported by allen who not only
encouraged them to submit in the first
place but has provided expert feedback
on cartoons like this one a knight is
trying to get into the castle to get to
the princess and the dragons like go
away she doesn't want to see you and i
did not give the princess a nose and
emma was like
this is great but can you just draw a
nose
and did you think emma in retrospect was
right the princess needed a nose um
didn't hurt and by bringing in a new
generation of new yorker cartoonists the
hope is a new generation of readers will
follow
not only for the articles
but for the laughs
part of the joy of it is that you can
run a new yorker cartoon that is a very
unsophisticated
dumb
joke and you can run a new yorker
cartoon that is a you know alludes to a
relatively obscure line of poetry
and both of those things can exist in
the same place and is every single
person who reads the new yorker going to
like both of those no
but i want there to be an accessible
point for anyone who is coming to new
york or cartoons and wants to have a
laugh
see a bit of their life represented
i like her i i love that this tradition
is like 100 years old at the new yorker
but it's got a renaissance online
because it's essentially an instagram
post with text right it's like a meme so
before there was a first meme yeah uh
and the other cool thing is
anyone can submit a cartoon and they are
constantly looking for new people so
there's a they have a look though those
cartoons they're called workers uh i i
think it's a call it's a panel so
there's a one panel and it's usually
black and white but within that context
you can do anything you want in that box
wait by anyone you're talking any age
you can just submit it and draw a doodle
right now on the back of this here and
swipe it in first i like seeing the
process that goes into it i like the yes
no maybe one of my favorite parts is to
hear david remnick totally who was an
icon in the industry go gaga gugu it's
so funny
all the national magazine awards and the
prizes they all get in the room and
they're like the sausage talking
that was good